[Música]
la semana pasada dos noticias se
llamaron la atención de oriente medio
Los Rebeldes sutidez y la coalición
liderada por Arabia Saudita en apoyo al
gobierno yemení comenzaron un
intercambio de prisioneros como parte de
los diálogos de paz llevados a cabo en
Suiza por otro lado surgió la noticia de
que se puede estar planteando la vuelta
de Siria a la liga árabe tras su
expulsión en 2011 al inicio de su Guerra
Civil son dos noticias que suman a lato
retoma de relaciones entre Arabia
Saudita e Irán y Egipto y Turquía
parecen estar también descongelando sus
relaciones estos movimientos hacen
pensar en un cierto relajamiento de los
conflictos de la región para conversar
sobre la posibilidad de estabilización
de oriente medio hablamos con Carlos
Alberto Patiño quien es profesor de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia y
también experto en conflictos
internacionales contemporáneos y guerras
del Siglo 21 Carlos Gracias a usted
Hola buenos días después del saludo
Carlos se encamina realmente de oriente
medio hacia una relativa paz y Qué
factores se están dando para todos estos
acercamientos que hemos nombrado hace un
segundo
pues mire realmente creo que es muy
prematuro pensar que Oriente medio está
digamos acercando a una estabilidad
regional y que esta estabilidad regional
podría disminuir los confrontaciones
realmente es una buena noticia el
acercamiento Irán pero no hay que
olvidar que esto se da en el medio de
una competencia de hace más de una
década por la primacía geopolítica entre
árabes ahorita e Irán donde además en el
medio lo que está es la lucha por llenar
el vacío dejado por la desaparición de
San José luego de la invasión de Estados
Unidos a Irak Y en este contexto hay una
reconfiguración geopolítica realmente de
fondo también hace parte de esa
reconfiguración geopolítica la disputa
entre Turquía y Egipto y aquí habría que
recordar además un detalle Que para los
egipcios no parece estar olvidado y es
el apoyo que Turquía en su momento
brindó a el régimen de Mohamed morphy
representante de los hermanos musulmanes
que pretendía convertir una especie de
República islámica si bien desde el lado
sunita Que pretendiera de alguna manera
asumir lo que estaba sucediendo en Irán
o lo que ha sucedido en el Irán
Revolucionario con la conformación de la
República islámica de forma tal que las
tensiones intra islámicas están a la
orden del día y Habría que ver si esta
guerra intermediada o guerra por
delegación que se ha hecho en los
últimos años Pues logrará algún final en
este acuerdo o en estas conversaciones
entre los cutis y los autitas claro y es
que el profesor uno se pregunta también
si puede haber una paz verdadera
mientras que algunos de países es muy
importante eso como irá como Líbano como
Siria por solo nombrar algunos de los
ejemplos sigan sin solucionar sus
conflictos internos
es que realmente es muy difícil Irak la
estabilidad dirá que está lejos de
obtenerse Además porque al Gran vencedor
con el derrocamiento de sadampusein en
iraku fue Irán Irán yendo los espacios y
y los vacíos de poder que hace los
sauditas no pudieron llenar y que fueron
producto de los errores de la invasión
de los Estados Unidos a Irak y
adicionalmente el problema del Líbano es
una un estado sin solución sin
continuidad sin posibilidad de salida y
adicionalmente Francia que veas el gran
Valedor de del Líbano pues no tiene
ningún protagonismo que jugar en Líbano
y el Líbano es mucho más que un estado
fracasado es una sociedad completamente
fracturada en la imposibilidad de un
estado sometida además a al control de
una fuerza muy compleja que dejes volar
que no es parte estructural de
estructural o estructurante del estado
libanés o de lo que puede ser el estado
Olivares Y en este contexto realmente
hay un conjunto de sociedades
fracturadas muy difícilmente
reinstitucionalizables y en ese contexto
Pues suponer que Oriente medio va a
entrar a una etapa una etapa de
estabilización realmente es muy difícil
Pero además sociedades que han sido
intervenidas En diferentes niveles por
el extranjero no entonces potencias como
Francia como Reino Unido con sus
acuerdos o Estados Unidos o Rusia
incluso han buscado imponer por supuesto
sus intereses en Oriente medio frente al
de las propias naciones de la región
usted considera que estas naciones están
ahora más libres de las ataduras
externas y esto permite la realización
de algunos acuerdos
pues eso es lo que han pretendido y en
todo caso Arabia Saudita que no hay que
olvidar que es una monarquía absoluta ha
intentado crear su propia esfera de
seguridad y su propia rol digamos
político geopolítico en este contexto y
aquí adicionalmente hay una algo que no
hay que olvidar es que el acuerdo entre
el área Saudita e Irán se producen dos
momentos muy diferentes eh digamos de la
política internacional un momento en el
que Irán se encuentra en uno de sus
momentos de mayor debilidad en la
política interna desde las Revolución en
1979 por todo el conjunto de protestas Y
en especial por todo el desafío que las
mujeres han planteado la República
islámica hasta el punto de que a muchas
observadores internos dirán consideran
que se encuentra en un nuevo estado muy
muy de muy de crisis que podría llevar
incluso a la caída de la República
islámica y a su vez encontrado los
límites de los que podría alcanzar como
monarquía absoluta de forma tal que
asistiendo a un acuerdo Irán árabes
Saudita en dos momentos realmente muy
peculiares en el cual además una
monarquía absoluta que pretende
reconfigurar su entorno inmediato de
acuerdo a sus intereses Ya ha encontrado
unos límites y unos alcances muy
complicados o una alianza con Pakistán
también muy difícil de gestionar y en el
en el intento además de obtener una
asistencia nuclear por parte de Pakistán
y en el caso de Irán validada por China
la República popular China y en medio de
la guerra con Ucrania intenta también
revalidar sus credenciales
internacionales y su presencia en
territorios como Irak o Líbano en este
contexto esto Más allá de los titulares
realmente Parece ser de muy difícil
gestión y creo que
la posibilidad de obtener un logro de
pacificación para el Oriente medio pues
se encuentra en una situación realmente
muy difícil mire y parece que a pesar de
todos los problemas que usted nos está
mencionando y explicando uno de los
puntos más alejados sigue siendo Israel
y la cuestión Palestina Israel que ya
oficializó relaciones por ejemplo con
Arabia Saudita y le pregunto siguen los
Países Árabes apoyando de manera fuerte
Palestina o se está logrando este
aislamiento por parte de Israel
realmente desde hace años la
organización de para la liberación de
Palestina la olp que es la la fuerza
política determinante y Palestina ha
tenido un resquebrajamiento muy fuerte
en el apoyo árabe a hacia ellos En parte
tiene que ver también por ejemplo con la
restauración del poder de los militares
dentro de Egipto y la el derrocamiento
de los hermanos musulmanes todo esto
producto de las desde el contexto de de
alzamientos y cambios políticos después
de las primaveras Árabes en 2011 y la
caída de mojada desde
esto ha hecho que los palestinos han
pasado por un periodo realmente de
aislamiento de muy poco apoyo árabe y en
ese contexto pues eh los palestinos se
encuentran en una situación muy difícil
además muy divididos entre la olp y y el
resto de organizaciones que pues están
por ejemplo presentes en gaza en ese
contexto Hay también una radicalización
y una profunda inestabilidad de Israel
lo que hemos visto en los últimos dos
meses de manifestaciones contra el
gobierno de jaimines Benjamín tanyahu ha
demostrado el retorno de los sectores
liberales de la sociedad israelí es
mucho más abiertos y que de alguna
manera han perdido una especie de
preponderancia desde la elección de
homenaje en 1978 y que pareciera ser su
momento de retorno de los sectores más
liberales en este contexto Israel se
encuentra frente a una transición en un
momento en el que los palestinos se
encuentran profundamente divididos y
aislados de un apoyo mayoritariamente
árabe y donde los árabes pareciera ser
que la causa Palestina no es una de sus
prioridades políticas o geopolíticas en
este momento pues mire Muchas gracias
Carlos Alberto Patiño profesor de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia experto
en conflictos internacionales
contemporáneos y guerras del Siglo 21 Le
deseo que tenga un feliz día
a usted muchas gracias y a nuestros
televidentes quédense con nosotros
Porque ya volvemos con más de directo a
América
[Música]